thank you
the chaotic aftermath of the attack on
Sir Salman rushed it the suspect is
tackled to the ground at the front of
the stage the badly injured author
receives first aid a few feet behind
members of the audience willing him to
survive
the man in custody has been identified
as 24 year old Hadi matar he was born in
California but had recently moved to
Fairview New Jersey and was sympathetic
to Shiite extremism according to law
enforcement sources I would never even
consider someone like like that living
in this neighborhood
you know it's unbelievable I thought
that maybe somebody got shot
I'm hearing all these helicopters I
didn't know what happened I lived right
around the corner terrible terrible
the 75 year old author was airlifted
from the scene in Western New York state
to a hospital in Pennsylvania where he's
undergone emergency surgery he said to
be in danger of losing one eye was
stabbed in the liver and nerves in his
arm were severed the investigation into
this audacious attack is continuing but
the suspect has now been charged with
attempted murder in the second degree he
was processed last night and transported
to Chautauqua County Jail
Salman Rushdie has lived under threat
since 1988 his depiction of the Prophet
Muhammad in his novel The Satanic Verses
enraged some Muslims Iran's leader
Ayatollah Khomeini imposed a death
sentence on the streets of Tehran
they've been responding to the attack
I heard the news on the TV and I was so
glad because of the insult salmon
Rushdie had made against our prophet and
the fat were issued against him finally
worked
they should know that sooner or later
the rights will always overcome God
willing he pays for what he did
world leaders have condemned the
stabbing Salman rushdie's spent his life
defending free speech he's engaged in a
very different battle now as the world
awaits news of his condition
David Blevins Sky News in Erie
Pennsylvania